do not drink as a shot under any
circumstances
what kind of idiot would shot this
anyway [ __ ] it let's do a shot
this could go really badly I'm scared
I'm gonna [ __ ] my pants that bottle was
[ __ ] terrifying photo of what looks
like a devil
tiny but threatening this is gonna be
like a really good day I'll get drunk
and then tomorrow I'll have a headache
and a burning [ __ ] I'm Asian I could
totally do this bring it on bottoms up
ohh ohh oh my god ohh in puff holy [ __ ]
what the actual [ __ ] I no longer have a
tongue my mouth is on fire my stomach
he's on fire I feel really lightheaded
right now well with my heart even
beating a little bit faster that's rude
that's [ __ ] just ironed I feel like
I'm pissing my pants but I know that I'm
not it feels like I've eaten chili and
then wash it out with the world's
hottest chili my tongue feels like it
looks like this guy right now this beers
doing nothing if you leave it in there
good that is for sure the spiciest thing
that I've ever had in my mouth I feel as
though I've had 6 vodka shots in a row
my toilet come tomorrow morning is it
going to be a [ __ ] nightmare I'm an
idiot and I don't learn from my mistakes
oh [ __ ] yeah I would do that again I
don't even understand why people would
drink that like why is that enjoyable
what I want to do now is play a game
with my friends on who can do the most
shots of this I might lose a friend to
death I would like to go home now please
these things liked this wasn't made for
humans only demons